it's seven o'clock this is Sky News
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
as ukrainians celebrate their forces
retaking her song After the Russian
military withdrawals we report from the
newly liberated region
they've left an enormous amount of
ammunition
crate after crate
just dumped
they left here about 24 hours ago they
just simply vanished from this place
two English
was lose a legal battle to stop home
office housing Asylum seekers in hotels
the government insists Dominic Robb
values civil servants after reports
claimed the Deputy Prime Minister was
rude to staff
in the U.S President Biden's Democrats
are now just one seat away from keeping
control of the Senate after former
Astronaut Astronaut Mark Kelly project
is projected to win Arizona
after years as a climate Outcast
Australia says it's back and ready to
commit to Global pledges
the women's Rugby World Cup final
between England and New Zealand is
underway
yes
and England are leading This World Cup
final against the blackburns but what a
slender lead it is at the moment 19
points to 40 and they are a woman down
the weather mild today with lighter
winds and sunny spells to come once any
overnight fog lifts and rain clears from
the north
and a quarter two will be going through
the papers with the editor of Spike Tom
Slater and the journalist and author
Janelle aldred
a very good morning welcome to Sky News
breakfast president zielinski has
praised his people's resilience as the
Ukrainian flag was raised over the key
southern city of her son after the
withdrawal of Russian troops Ukrainian
forces were welcomed as they arrived in
the center of the city which was annexed
as a Russian territory in September
Russian forces still control large
swathes of the region which Moscow says
it still views as part of Russia our
International correspondent Alex Rossi
has this report from the newly liberated
areas surrounding her son
it is a moment they've longed to see and
the Euphoria of Liberation was
impossible to contain
ing soldiers were given a hero's welcome
as the crowd chanted for the military
the only Regional Capital captured by
Russia in its failing invasion was back
under kiev's control
at the police headquarters there was
also Joy with the blue and yellow of the
national flag flying proudly once again
yes just slowly I'm happy to see how
people despite all the threats despite
the repression and abuse of the
occupiers protected the Ukrainian Flags
believed in Ukraine
and the speed of Ukraine's Advance on
the southern front has been staggeringly
fast
the Russians were here and then they
were gone endless trenches simply
abandoned
in this Village selfies with soldiers
ended nine frightening months of
occupation for these women like everyone
else here it is an emotional time
and as people adjust to their New
Freedom there is an outpouring of
national pride Yuri tells me he can't
believe the Russians have left
um
but these areas are still far from safe
the soldiers here say they've already
removed more than 300 mines around the
village
this is where the Russians were
they've left an enormous amount of
ammunition
crate after crate
just dumped
they left here about 24 hours ago they
just simply vanished from this place
but you can see all the bombs down here
that they've left
it's been taken over now by Ukrainian
soldiers
as they move through this Village
everywhere they go they keep finding
more ammunition more things that have
just been discarded by the Russians
in this bunker Sergey shows me rows of
mortars he says the Russians had no
choice but to leave in a hurry and it
won't be long before the rest of the
country is liberated
the Russian Retreat here is another
humiliation for Moscow abandoned
positions and uniforms now symbols of a
botched invasion
and they are already ripping down all
signs of Russia's presence
this victory for Ukraine is a big moment
but this war is far from over
Alex Rossi Sky News
earlier I spoke to humanitarian worker
Julia pogrevnia Naya who has been
visiting villages in her son she told me
what she has discovered so far in the
newly liberated areas we see a huge need
for the civilian population in basic and
food and hygiene and medical
but at the same time the moods is very
very positive and
people are rejoicing today is a big day
for our country and um
it truly was worth this eight months of
suffering people are
are happy with their eyes full of tears
and
we all believe that this is just one
step closer to the victory
two councils have lost bids for high
court injunctions to prevent hotels in
their area from housing Asylum Seekers
Sky's shiman Freeman Powell is outside
the home office in central London Forest
this morning good morning uh to you
shiman now several councils are seeking
legal action over this issue of migrants
being put in hotels in their areas so an
interesting ruling here what more can
you tell us
well I can tell you it's significant but
it's by no means the end of the story so
just to explain what this means so
basically we already know don't we of
some of the conditions of manston
Immigration Center the last couple of
weeks and there have been reports of
overcrowding and some of the Asylum
seekers in there claiming that they had
been housed in in Dreadful conditions so
the home office have been trying to do
something about this by acquiring hotels
for these Asylum Seekers to stay in but
some local authorities aren't happy they
claim that by housing these Asylum
seekers in these hotels it changes the
material use of the building and
therefore it breaks planning conditions
so what the high court
um and because of that they had actually
applied for an interim injunction which
stopped the use of these hotels so it
meant that Asylum Seekers couldn't stay
in these hotels for the meantime so what
this in the high court ruling meant
yesterday is the judge had to decide
what happens to Asylum Seekers whilst
this bait this bigger debate about
whether or not it breaks breaks planning
rules continues so there will be a
further hearing on the issues of the the
planning debate however this High Court
ruling yesterday said that until this
debate can be had until this could be
heard in court that the hotels do have
to allow Asylum Seekers to stay there so
the judge had to judge Mr Justice
Holgate had to weigh up the arguments of
this idea of material change and in the
meantime what it meant to Asylum Seekers
and with the harm of Asylum Seekers and
their concerns involved too and he
concluded that the factors in favor of
discharging the injunction so getting
rid of the injunction clearly outweigh
those in favor of continuing it and he
denied that request the same was also
done for local authorities representing
Stoke on Trent city council as well now
what the local authorities say is that
by housing exclusively housing Asylum
seekers in the hotels it changes the
material use because it means that it's
no longer accessible to the public as
well as that Circle security guards can
often be placed on the front doors to
ensure the safety of Asylum Seekers but
also to ensure that the public don't
enter as well so they argue on top of
that that it can also have a huge impact
to the finances of the local Authority
as well as some of these hotels are in
Hot Spot areas but the judge has to
decide and has to weigh up these
arguments in the meantime about what
happens to the Asylum Seekers so that's
why they're allowed to be housed at
these hotels in the meantime but there
will be further hearings towards the end
of the year about the bigger debate and
the bigger issues as I said but more
broadly this is all about what to do
with the increased numbers of Asylum
Seekers that are traveling to the UK and
trying to get Refugee status and more
broadly we are hearing reports now that
Britain has come to some sort of
agreement with France over the channel
Crossings or welcome to some sort of
agreement as early as Monday so we are
hearing reports that the French are
agreeing that they may put more police
on beaches they will help to prevent
small brokes from leaving and they will
create a Joint Center and this is all
about making um the route uneconomic for
the Smugglers that often priorities
Asylum Seekers
okay shiman for now thank you
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt has promised
he'll work to make a possible recession
shallower and quicker after the latest
figures showed the economy had
contracted by 0.2 percent so what might
that mean for his Autumn statement this
coming week well our political
correspondent Rob Powell joins me now
from Westminster hello again Rob uh just
five days away from this all-important
fiscal statement and a difficult
backdrop with these latest GDP figures
for the chancellor what can we expect
well I think there's been quite a few
leaks into the newspapers a pretty
comprehensive briefing operation going
on for the last few weeks so I think we
can see the sort of broad shape of maybe
what is coming on Thursday I think it's
probably looking more likely than it was
that pensions and benefits will be
increased next year by the level of
rising prices rather than other lower
pegs such as earnings but I think
because of that that's a sort of
expensive move there may have to be more
savings or more money raised elsewhere
and I think in terms of where the
chancellor and Mishi sunak look to try
and do that in the tax system you'll
probably see some of the more kind of
fiddly bits of the tax system being
looked at so by that I mean not
necessarily the headline rates of tax
but things like thresholds the point at
which people start paying increased
rates of say income tax there has been
numerous reports about an extension to
the freeze on income tax Thresh and what
that essentially means is that as people
get pay Rises and earn more they're
dragged into higher tax brackets and
hence more tax comes into the government
there could be also things like pension
tax relief looked at or allowances on
capital gains tax as well now all of
these things are sort of called stealth
taxes because they are not the big
ticket headline rates
um
of tax changes that also means they
don't necessarily raise as much as if
you were playing around with the overall
rates of tax the danger of course though
is if they start going hunting for
changes that are more pronounced in the
tax system that risks a backlash from
the conservative back benches I think
the other unknown as well is around
spending and how that shakes down to the
various departments who are all coping
of course with demands for high pay
settlements from their workers and also
generally with the higher rate of
inflation
and a big splash on the front page of
the Guardian uh today Rob adding to more
allegations about uh government bullying
what can you tell us on that yeah so the
Guardian newspaper is reporting uh that
Dominic Robb the Justice secretary and
Deputy Prime Minister uh accusations
connected to him regarding bullying
unnamed sources quoted by the guardian
saying that senior officials in his
Department
um were when he was reappointed there
last month were offered a root out or
respite amid concerns that when he was
in the ministry of justice under Boris
Johnson he created what the guardian
quotes as a Culture of Fear now it's
also says the paper also says that the
most senior civil servant there the
permanent secretary had to speak to
Dominic Robb when he came back into the
department last month to urge him to
treat civil servants with respect and
treat them in a professional way now
those close to Arab sources connect to
the Justice secretary have categorically
denied any accusations of bullying they
say that he is a good working
relationship with his civil servants the
suggestion seems to be that yes he's
someone that expects and asks a lot of
his staff but that he asks a lot of
himself and holds himself to high
standards as well the ministry of
Justice have also put out a statement
saying that there's zero tolerance for
bullying and that the minister the
Deputy Prime Minister values the civil
servants that he works with
um I think at the moment what you are
getting is unnamed allegations going to
newspaper journalists the difficulty I
think really starts with the Deputy
Prime Minister amishi sunak is if
something more solid comes forward as it
did with Gavin Williamson who of course
had to resign earlier in the week okay
Rob for now thank you
let's have a look at other stories
making the news this morning and in the
US the Democrats Mark Kelly is projected
to win re-election to the senate in the
Battleground State of Arizona it brings
President Biden's party a step closer to
holding its majority in the upper
chamber of Congress Democrats now only
need one more seat to maintain control
of the Senate since the vice president
Kamala Harris can cast tie-breaking
votes
meanwhile president Trump has launched
legal action aimed to avoid being forced
to testify in front of a panel
investigating the January the sixth
Capital riots the committee had issued a
subpoena which would have forced the
former president to give evidence next
week president Trump's lawyers argue the
warrant breaches his right to free
speech
now Banksy appears to have confirmed he
is in Ukraine after unveiling these new
artworks on Instagram the anonymous
graffiti artists shared photos of a
mural depicting a female gymnast
balancing on a pile of rubble from a
damaged building which he claims is in
borgianka which is just outside Kiev
similar murals though unverified have
appeared in the city in recent weeks
now President Biden has addressed the
cop 27 climate Summit in Egypt calling
on the global Community to come together
to tackle climate change the summit
continues to be dominated by questions
over whether tough climate targets can
be met and whether richer countries
should compensate poorer ones for past
activities that damaged their
environment
every nation has needs to step up
at this Gathering we must renew and
raise our climate ambitions
countries that are in a position to help
should be supporting developing
countries so they can make decisive
climate decisions
facilitating their energy transitions
building a path to prosperity and
compatible with our climate imperative
if countries can Finance coal in
developing countries there's no reason
why we can't finance Clean Energy in
development companies
and joining me now is the UK's climate
change high level Champion Nigel topping
a very good morning to you thank you for
joining us President Biden urged
countries to double down on their
climate commitments at cop yesterday how
would those comments received
well very well when they're backed up by
some of the the money that he committed
whether it's to supporting Egypt or
Indonesia in their energy transitions so
in case of Egypt getting rid of
gas-fired power and ramping up
Renewables in the case of Indonesia and
facing down coal much quicker but also
very well in the context of the
inflation reduction act which is a
massive stimulus to American industry to
go clean and much faster and in the
context of what was um the real topic
yesterday what we call the Breakthrough
agenda many many countries and companies
collaborating to drive down the cost and
up the volume of Steel cement hydrogen
so that the the cleanest technology the
zero carbon technology becomes the
cheapest one by 2030 and then can be
rolled out across the world much faster
uh new analogy new analysis which was
revealed at cop27 showed who's
responsible for the missing Target of
100 billion dollars a year Finance for
developing nations and the U.S fell
rather short uh on that didn't they
yeah they're they're very low down
obviously they're starting from a very
low base of zero under the trunk years
and and Biden's been working to ramp
that up um still a long way from what
would be their fair share considering
the size of their economy
um and I guess the the midterms will be
uh material in the extent to which Biden
has the ability to build that up more so
I I think we recognize he's doing what a
lot domestically and and as much as he
can with his hands tied somewhat
um internationally but everyone's
looking to see those numbers come up
from America that's for sure yes
certainly and all eyes on the midterms
in terms of how much tougher that will
be for President Biden uh if they lose
the house which it does look like they
will
um but in terms of those big statements
that we hear at cop you know we heard
them last year in Glasgow were hearing
this year in Egypt from Antonio
Gutierrez from Rishi sunak from
President Biden is there a sense that
okay you know we've heard this before
now what we want is action
well I mean there's not a sense of
euphoria that we solved the problem
that's for sure because we know from all
the science that we're way behind still
but there is a very strong sense and the
Egyptians have been really pushing this
this is an implementation card and that
and that if you like lofty promises that
were made and we're now seeing the
granular level of activity
um you know yesterday I was just looking
at looking at the steel and cement
there's four times as many low carbon
cement projects actually being built now
than there were last year the 60 million
tons worth of green steel projects in
the pipeline including some um to some
announced one a couple of months ago two
billion dollars to make two and a half
million tons of green steel from Green
hydrogen so the senses shifting here
that was less about negotiations that
are some sorts and big things to be
negotiated like loss and damage and much
more about how we can speed up the
industrial transition and the
encouraging thing is that we know that
that transition always happens
exponentially as volumes go up costs
come down and that that drives that
virtuous circle which means we go much
much faster and a lot of the predictions
are saying at the moment
and obviously the biggest debate at this
conference is has been who is going to
pay for the loss and damage of climate
change on those uh poorer countries who
have been most affected is there any
progress on that there's been a big
representation from fossil fuel
companies at Cobb and suggestions that
they should be paying some of the share
any any encouragement that they would be
willing to do so
I haven't had any encouragement they
would be willing to do so I mean it's a
very logical
suggestion that those those of course
the problem should um pay some something
for the permission they've caused I
think we might see that building
momentum it won't be something that I
think can be negotiated
at the [ __ ] what we are seeing is
movement on things like early Warning
Systems you know a big push from the
Secretary General so that
um within a few years every country
um has the early warning systems that
reduces losses a lot if you know that
something's coming and you can prepare
for it and reduce the losses also a
growing um a shift from just focusing on
what can be negotiated within the UN
climate change talks to more broader
conversations for example about the
extending insurance coverage developing
countries only have about four percent
of climate losses covered and in
developed countries it's more like 50 so
something bad happens in a developing
country then the impact is much greater
because it creates that economic loss
which draws on the resources which
really need to be spent actually
financing the transition so I think
there's progress early days within
negotiations because of course we're
just halfway through and they've they're
laying out a timetable to really come up
with what everyone hopes will be at an
actual Fund in 2024 but that fund will
not be enough because it's such a big
and complicated issue so we need to
explore these other issues at some of
the couple that talked about
okay Nigel topping thanks for joining us
and best of luck as that granular detail
is discussed by diplomats and lawyers
this week thank you great thank you
well still to come we have all the sport
with Jackie
sorry thank you yes here at Apex tense
nervous Pub here in Twickenham and the
red roses are just have their noses in
front at half time in This World Cup
final against the black Furs leading the
back 26 points to 19 but my goodness
what drama we've had England are a woman
down Lydia Thompson sent off early on
for a reckless tackle so really all to
do but they're more doing the work at
the moment we'll have more on this more
reaction to this and the rest of the
sport after the break
foreign
for us for rather nail biting uh match
between the red roses and the black
ferns we lost Jackie for a second there
you are Jackie in uh that pub near to
Twickenham Stadium uh living your best
life at seven in the morning
I won't say that I think it's been a
very very tense Versa very exciting but
very uh very nail-biting England with
their noses in France just now but
really just one trying conversion in the
score lines as they lead 26 points to 19
at half time and it has been well it's
been a thriller so far the Pomeroy
family joined me now welcome guys hey
how have you found the first half really
exciting really exciting yeah play rugby
Alba don't you what did you feel when
England had a player sent off
um I'm not really sure it's just like
quite nerve-wracking because obviously
you've got players sent off and now
we're down Affair so it's quite
nerve-wracking really and he's not very
hard as a rugby player if you get
someone sent off yeah yeah very very
difficult dad what have you been
thinking so far they've been playing
playing quite smartly playing to their
strengths England aren't they they
absolutely are I'm super excited to see
the second half I think England is still
such a dominant pack I think we're going
to bring this one home
what do you think they've done well so
far I mean they they're determined
they've had the
I just think they've come out so
confident and they've done their Basics
really well their their line out scrum
time rock time has all been so
proficient and I think if they can just
keep that efficiency and Effectiveness
up they're going to be great stronger
out there they're stronger they're
bigger what do you think have you what's
your name Woody oh very great name and
what do you think has it been very
exciting so far yeah are you quite tired
did you get up quite early yeah what's
it worth it yeah yeah yeah let's hope
it's worth it in the end because you've
got to go and play rugby in a bit
haven't you got rugby training yourself
okay well done Pomeroy family thank you
so much enjoy enjoy the second half I
mean it is right now biting England on
this uh 30 match winning streak which is
the the greatest winning streak we've
ever seen in the history of Rugby Union
men or women but my goodness they know
they're in the final right now
foreign
it's only a game brought to you by
Vitality sharing the benefits of healthy
living
so let's have a look at some other
sports stories this morning and let's
stay with rugby because uh down the road
at Twickenham HQ a little bit later on
the England men's team uh we'll take on
Japan in the Autumn Internationals they
need to win they need to show that they
are winners convincingly having lost to
Argentina last weekend Ellie Jones under
a bit of pressure here he is yeah we had
a setback last week we acknowledge our
performance wasn't good enough and again
I take full responsibility for that but
we've had a really good week really
vibrant week and we're ready to take on
Japan
so that is all your score for now from a
very excited twicken and papa England
leading the black fans at half time and
are packed out Eden Park 40 000 watching
they all want the black ferns to win
obviously but it's England who leads at
half time at 26 points to 19. it's not
March but it's something
and we'll cross back to Jackie for
updates throughout that all-important
match this is Sky News breakfast coming
up of the break we'll have more on
Ukrainian forces retaking her song of
the Russian military withdraws I'll be
speaking to former National Security
advisors Sir Mark Lyle Grant
in the last hour the ministry of Defense
has said Russia's withdrawal from the
hersan region in the south of Ukraine
brings significant reputational damage
British intelligence analysts say
moscow's exit from the city likely began
as early as three weeks ago will joining
me now is former National Security
adviser samott Lyle Grant thank you for
joining us this morning
um what more can you add to that comment
from the ministry of Defense in the last
hour that this will have inflicted
significant reputational damage to
Russia
I think that's right Sally
um it's clearly a great victory for the
Ukrainian forces and it is a humiliating
defeat for President Putin and it's
noticeable that President Putin was not
present on air as it were when his
generals announced the withdrawal of the
Russian troops
um from Hassan don't forget that it's
only six weeks ago that President Putin
announced the annexation of four
provinces in eastern Ukraine
and he now doesn't control all of any of
those four provinces and has lost the
provincial capital Cresson
um which was the only major provincial
capital captured by the Russians after
their invasion in February this year so
it is a very significant moment
yeah absolutely and it's interesting you
raise
um those uh referenda that took place
six weeks ago where four uh
russian-controlled areas of Ukraine were
essentially annexed and in these uh in
this sort of um charade of a referenda
that was that was held um have they made
any material difference to what's
actually happening in Ukraine or is it
simply for a bit of posturing and and
for uh President Putin's political
messaging back home that he can call
these regions Russia
well the referendum are significant for
Russia because technically after these
annexations they become Russian soil so
arguably Ukraine has now Taken part of
Russia now for the ultra nationalists in
Russia and we're seeing some of this
playing out on the Russian social media
that is very embarrassing because you've
got a small neighbor essentially taking
what Putin has declared is Russian
territory so that is absolutely
backfired on President Putin
and certainly that's just the Optics
isn't it for the Russian domestic
audience because in terms of the
legality of those referenda those areas
aren't part of Russia
no indeed and you know if you look at
the dancing scenes very moving scenes in
clear song last night and this morning
where the inhabitants are clearly
welcoming Ukrainian troops and are
delighted that the Russians have left it
just gives the lie to the Sham
referendum as you mentioned Sally and
shows that clearly the inhabitants of
the city never wanted the Russians to be
there and are delighted that it's now
back in Ukrainian hands yeah it
certainly caused doubt on those
so-called results of 98 of their
population of those areas voting in
favor becoming part of Russia but just
going back to that point made by the
ministry of Defense in the last hour
that um this withdrawal from her son uh
really does represent reputational
damage for Russia are we are we talking
um reputational damage internationally
or domestically
well I think internationally certainly
and with some of Russia's allies like
China I mean if you look at the
relationship between Russia and China
what Russia brought to that relationship
was its military power now that military
power over the last nine months has been
shown to be something of a paper tiger
and so that is very damaging I think for
some of Russia's uh traditional allies I
think within Russia the vast majority of
the Russian people are still only
getting one version of the truth and
that is the one put out by the Kremlin
but the oligarchs around President Putin
will have seen the truth and I think
Putin's reputation as being a hard man
of being a winner has certainly taken a
huge knock and that puts his position of
power in some Jeopardy in Moscow
and so what do you see happening now
what do you think Vladimir Putin's next
move will be he's receiving a
significant amount of criticism from
military bloggers back home now and
there seemed to be rather few options
for him and certainly and some
significant failures in terms of what's
happened on the battlefield recently
well I think President zielinski's right
to be cautious I mean this is a great
victory for Ukraine and they should
certainly celebrate it but the reality
on the ground is the Russian troops have
now fallen back to the east of the
danipro river and into much more
defensible positions and I don't think
the ukrainians are actually capable of
attacking Russians across that River
apart from anything else all the bridges
have been destroyed and so I think what
we'll see over the next two three months
during the winter is a time for one more
static position on the front line on the
battlefield
um and unlikely to be ability either the
ukrainians to attract the Russians or
the Russians to significantly attack the
ukrainians
okay a smart Lyle Grant thank you very
much indeed for your thoughts today
thank you thank you very much
after years as a climate Outcast
Australia says it's back and ready to
commit to Global pledges to save the
world from destroying itself at the last
[ __ ] conference Australia promised
nothing new but Nicole Johnston reports
from the Northern New South Wales on
what a difference a year makes
too risky to stay too expensive to go
lismore's flood refugees live in limbo
when the River Rose and the city went
under in a deluge so great and so fast
it sent muddy water coursing through the
streets
Marco tool and his family were saved in
the nick of time that moment I'll never
forget when the helicopter came in the
downforce of that helicopter was just
unbelievable it was lifting my roof
right off the house
smashed by a wall of water his house
still stands
but ravaged by flood it's been stripped
bare and reeks of Decay now we've got no
walls the roof from the army helicopter
just leaks everywhere it looks unlivable
really yeah we've got no power it's full
of mold we can't live in it
and you can't live here either
condemned houses torn down
or left to rot
covered in a thick film of muck there's
hundreds of people homeless people
living in the shells of their homes
people camping in their front or
backyards just to survive and we know
that unless we take real action to
stabilize the climate that these extreme
weather events will keep on happening
so the country's new government has
promised to shift to renewable energy
cut methane gas emissions by a third
and reduce greenhouse gas emissions by
more than 40 percent in the next seven
years Australia has gone from being a
climate outlier to saying that it's back
at the international table and with a
plan to cut its emissions faster and
deeper than ever before
after a decade of dithering there's a
lot of ground to make up look at the
last cop conference we had no pledges we
had a low Target we were doing nothing
now we've had an election people have
voted with their feet they want more
we've doubled our Target we've got all
sorts of policies newly in place so
we've gone from an F to you know a sort
of a b
it's not enough out here on the flood
plain
we really can't leave because we are
we're stuck
uh we can't sell our properties for
anything
um so we can't move
hear the sound of coming rain begets
Terror and Trauma
fear of the next great flood in
Australia's deepening climate disaster
Nicole Johnston
Sky News Lismore
a scientist from Oxford has started her
own biotech firm in a bid to find
life-extending treatment for her
daughter's incurable nervous system
disorder Dr Michelle Tang's daughter
Sophia has a rare condition that affects
just dozens of newborns in the UK each
year and she hopes clinical trials for
the treatment could begin within two
years either Bennett has this report
foreign
counts because Michelle knows her time
with her daughter may be rapidly running
out
Sophia has a rare deadly and incurable
disease called tub foray leukodystrophy
now 12 she first presented symptoms
nearly a decade ago
case scenarios the children die within
12 months and I had no idea how long she
was going to live for you know the
doctors told us there's nothing you can
do
and I think it's probably the most
devastating
kind of news that you can you know for
any parent to hear
I couldn't accept it
that's why I decided to do something
about it
at first that something was to raise
money for research but as Sophia's
condition worsened from a healthy
toddler to a child unable to walk or
talk Michelle took Research into her own
hands a scientist by trade she set up a
company to find a cure
I feel like
because we've set up this company we are
finally in a driving seat and finding a
treatment for her
within those timelines you know that we
believe
will be on time for her
the company's based in Oxford and has
teamed up with a leading Children's
Hospital in America hopeful it will
reach clinical trials within the next
two years
one of the most horrible things is that
a lot of these children don't actually
make it into late teenagers
and hopefully by stopping the
progression of this disease it could
offer them
a better quality of life as well as
an extension to their lives as well this
is a potential Game Changer it is it is
a potential Game Changer yes
part of the reason why there's no cure
for this disease yet is because it was
actually only identified eight years ago
in 2014 and the other reason is because
it's incredibly rare it's thought to
only affect between 60 and 90 newborns
in Britain each year and just over 1600
worldwide
for those it does affect it is a ticking
Time Bomb but Michelle says Sophia
doesn't let it get to her and that
they'll never give up hope of finding a
cure either Bennett Sky News Oxford
right time now for a look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
rain in the north will clear to leave
largely dry in very mild conditions this
weekend however overnight fog will
become more prevalent especially across
England and Wales will be mostly dry
with patches of low Cloud mist and fog
this morning
meanwhile much of Scotland and Ireland
will be cloudy with outbreaks of rain
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you're watching Sky News breakfast
coming up we'll be taking you through
the morning's papers with the deputy
editor of Spike Tom Slater and the
journalist and author Janelle aldrew
that's next
now with us this morning to review the
papers is the editor of spiked Tom
Slater and the journalist and author
Janelle aldred thank you both for
joining us again let's start with you
first Janelle you've picked out the
front uh of the Ft weekend uh certainly
it's been a very turbulent time for the
crypto world and one huge company has
filed bankruptcy tell us about that
yeah they've um lost well the empire was
worse than 32 billion dollars FTX
um they have file for bankruptcy their
founder has resigned um he's a 30 year
old man Sam beatman Sam bankman fried
and what happened this week that was
basically a run on it and what so people
tried to take their money out and they
couldn't essentially meet the demand of
people trying to withdraw their money
and so he had to file for bankruptcy and
this has led to obviously more
conversation around crypto I think when
you're not so Savvy in crypto I'm not
that that Savvy in it it's easy to
dismiss it but I think like many things
to do with online and fintech it will go
through several iterations
um this has also affected Bitcoin so
their um stocks have dropped by about 60
this year already what happened
yesterday has led to a further drop in
it and so I think what this will do is
probably open up a lot of conversation
around cryptocurrency bring it more into
the mainstream and also think about what
it should look like in the future that a
business in just over three years had a
32 billion dollar valuation which has
managed to be sunk in just a week should
lead to bigger questions about crypto
it's not there's no oversight there is
oversight that seems like there should
be a bigger conversation around crypto
the future of money I never carry any
cash cashlessness does seem like the
future so it seems like a great time to
open up this conversation
uh interesting stuff Janelle and and Tom
you've pulled out a double page spread
inside the guardian from the team
reporting there in Ukraine are some
really interesting testimony about what
civilians have been through during the
occupation of her son obviously the that
area that is being liberated at the
moment
yeah some great photos there of the sort
of jubilant scenes of residents greeting
that their liberators
um as this really key sort of strategic
city has been retaken in another sort of
stunning counter-offensive this was of
course the sort of first Regional
Capital that um Putin's in Vegas managed
to capture it was the entire region of
uh kesson was effectively annexed by
Russia formerly after some sham
referendum about six weeks ago so the
level of humiliation is is probably off
the scale from anything we've seen
previously even the botched attempt to
hit Kiev at the beginning of the
invasion or the counter-offensive in the
northeast of the country as well so just
another really stunning
counter-offensive from the ukrainians
there and again you see the people
spinning out on the streets completely
giving the the lie to Putin's line that
these people were just waiting to be
liberated by Mother Russia certainly
that's not the scenes you see on the
streets there they certainly seem to
speak to speak for themselves uh an
unthinkable you know what some of them
may have been through since that
occupation began in March uh Janelle
onto the economy uh you pulled out uh
this article I think it's in the times
uh about uh next week's fiscal statement
that we'll be getting from Jeremy Hunt
uh you know suggestions uh that it will
be bad news for almost everyone
yeah it's looking like a return to
austerity and unprecedented tax rises in
peacetime someone said the good news or
want Tory MPS have the good news is what
services won't be cut and what tax Rises
don't actually happen I think there's
probably not many people who are not
worrying or thinking about what this
will mean for them and their finances
and apparently hunt and soon Knack have
met about five times this week in the
cabinet room and there's a feeling in
the seems like a thinly veiled truce in
the Tory party about what this budget
could mean for the party and for their
election chances in terms of if it does
go wrong or doesn't go as well as they'd
hoped what that will mean for them what
that will mean for the markets some Tory
MPS are worried that Jeremy Hunt is
going to try to over correct what Liz
trust set in motion
um we've heard from quasiquarting this
week you know kind of a preemptive get
ahead of the narrative or try to and um
saying that the problems that are
occurring didn't just happen in the 44
days that Liz truss was in charge and
he's right because I'm old enough to
remember the last round of austerity it
didn't work then and I'm sure if they
cut too deeply it won't work now poverty
does trickle upwards you know it might
money might not trickle down but poverty
does trickle up even if you want to if
you want to grow that people can't
afford to buy things because their bills
are going up the taxes are going up
there's a talk that Council taxes could
also rise then how will they have money
to spend how will they have anything
left over how can the economy begin to
grow so I'm really rooting that this
government have the right message have
the right plan and I think you know
whether or not you support the Tory
party we should all be really invested
in this going right for us because if it
goes wrong some devastating consequences
we're already behind other countries in
terms of our growth postcovid yeah and
just on that Tom on on that lack of
growth post covid for the UK do you
think part of the problem is that we
have had this Whiplash in terms of
Economic Policy from a pretty unstable
Tory party
I think that's certainly part of it
although at the same time I feel like
there was a lot of kind of Market
irrationalism in response to trust is
very incoherent plan for the economy
certainly but one that I don't think
warranted the sort of response that we
we saw we're just in a very febrile
International economic climate at the
moment and for all the kind of Tory
complacency we did have a fundamentally
weak economy going into this longest
squeeze on living standard sits in the
polionic wars flatlining productivity
growth for so long we were very exposed
so a kind of crack up was coming it just
turned out for some reason that that
mini budget and all the Mad politics
around it is what seemed to spark all of
everything sort of come crashing down if
you like and Janelle you pulled out this
story in the express about Alex Sharma
warning um on delaying on climate action
oh I think that might be Tom Tom quick
line
yes so um closing the uh cop 27. at uh
charmel shake the outgoing president of
cop
um alak Sharma saying that the cost of
inaction is going to be significantly
more than the cost of action I do sort
of wonder what cost is it that he's
talking about I mean with Net Zero it's
kind of you know it's in the trillions
in terms of the amount that it's
potentially going to cost and I think
that particularly with the economic
climate they're at the moment things
like Net Zero effectively like fantasies
that the working class of this country
can't can't stand at this point I think
that if you want to do something about
climate you can't do it in a certain way
it's going to make people worse off and
given the fact that we are on this
energy crisis we need to get serious
about this aside from the questions of
warmers you've also got to make sure
there is cheap and reliable energy and I
think that's something which is so
missing from this discussion oftentimes
okay I think we'll have to leave it
there we'll see you both again next hour
Tom Slater and Janelle aldred thank you
both so much for joining us